John isn't really my father so he needs
to know the truth
we stand accused of murder
we stand accused of treason
the last thing you're ever going to see
is a stark smiling down at you as you
die the time has come in three eyed
Raven winter is here the war is not both
a Nike it will find his way to the world
and then when he does it will be there
waiting for him
in winter we must protect ourselves and
the snows fall and the white winds blow
the lone wolf dies but the pack survives
hey everybody its charlie HBO dropped
the new promo for a game of Thrones
Season 8 just for House Stark so I
wanted to do a video for House Stark
predictions just for those characters
although you kind of have to include
Daenerys now as part of Jon Snow
predictions because she's so tied up in
his story during Season eight so we'll
do a new round of the book giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I know there's a lot of questions
about when the next trailer is gonna
drop also include information about that
in the video too so the funny thing
about this promo is that they're
actually using Daenerys as rain theme as
well as Cersei is a light of the seven
theme instead of any of the start
Winterfell themes like the scene that
they end on with Sansa having that
famous quote the lone wolf dies but the
pack survives they put it in all the
season seven trailers it's a big theme
going into season eight because it's
very relevant again because of Jon
Snow's heritage the name of the music
playing over the scene of Santa actually
saying that in the season seven finale
was called winter has come but that
appears nowhere in this promo maybe
because they felt like it wasn't too
energetic in the light of the seven is
probably one of the best theme songs
that they've ever had on the show for
any particular moment but the other
thing that I like about this promote
that they remind you is when you have
Arya Stark and Sansa in the crypts of
Winterfell in front of Ned Stark statute
and they mirror that conversation that
Arya Stark is having with Ned Stark
during season one about winter is coming
we Starks we need to protect ourselves
there's been a lot of attention focused
in the last couple of promos and
trailers the game of Thrones is released
for Season eight on the Winterfell Crips
they even went as far to officially
title the last big trailer they released
as the Winterfell Crips trailer so even
though a lot of those scenes I don't
think will wind up in the actual
episodes the actual crypts at Winterfell
and Ned Stark himself his statue will be
important to the season eight episodes
particularly when Jon Snow is learning
the truth about his parentage but these
are my top 10 predictions for the stark
characters and a lot of these are based
on the footage that we've already got
the interviews that the actors have done
and what the producers have said like
all the public facing information that
we have
starting with number 10 the season
begins with the scene of Jon Snow
Daenerys arriving at Winterfell greeted
by Sansa probably Arya hopefully brain
is also there too so that all the star
children are there in that first scene
but it's also intended to be a parallel
reference to the scene of Robert
Baratheon arriving with his procession
at Winterfell in the very first episode
so obviously all those awkward
introductions that you have in that
first episode the funny almost standoff
that they have like it almost looks like
Daenerys is having a brief little
standoff with sauce up everyone's been
playing it for memes I don't think it'll
be quite so crazy in the actual episode
when we're watching it but number 9 the
footage that we've already gotten has
shown us and been corroborated by sophie
turner and the producers that Sansa
opens the season not trusting Daenerys
at all she's not happy to host her her
army her dragons at Winterfell because
the North remembers that the Mad King
burned Rickard stark alive and forced
Brandon Stark to strangle himself in the
attempt to save him so they entered the
season with all that baggage but also
Sansa isn't really happy about John
bending the knee and his relationship
with Daenerys either but that's before
she spends any time with Daenerys or
gets to know her at all this is just all
of her preconceived notions and
everything that she's learned about the
Targaryen growing up number 8 bran stark
and Samwell told us in the season 7
finale that they really want to tell Jon
Snow the truth about his parents Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna Stark and thanks to
extra context from Samwell and Gilly
they also really want to tell him that
he's not a bastard and is actually the
rightful heir to the Iron Throne of
Westeros a head of Daenerys long live
the king Aegon Targaryen long may he
reign so even though there's a big
question about when they're actually
going to tell him because I think
they'll try early in the episode but
won't actually be able to complete that
until around the first big battle with
the night king and the White Walkers
because when things go wrong they all go
wrong at the same time in what better
time for Jon Snow to get hit with that
information right before they actually
have this giant battle with the night
king and the White Walkers so that he's
trying to process that but also deal
with the very real threat of death at
their door the reason why they would
wait to tell him just from a dramatic
structural perspective is is that
anytime the characters feel like they
get to safe or everyone's too happy with
themselves or when there's no drama is
when a writer typically sets off a big
drama bomb like jon snow's true identity
going off at everyone's faces but just
from a narrative perspective number
seven before they set off that big jon
snow drama bomb the drama between Sansa
and Daenerys settles and they find a
mutual respect for each other even if
they're not gonna be best friends or
anything like that because it's hard to
imagine Sansa ever getting really
excited or super happy about anything
ever again just look at her face
through all of season seven even when
she's relatively content like she feels
like she's doing the right thing she's
got that stern look on her face that's
the new face of her contentment I think
that's as happy as she ever gets pending
a few big twists that are a little bit
lower on my list here that I'll talk
about in a second there are a couple of
things that could probably make her
really really happy but I don't think
that we'll see that to the very end of
the series so all the salsa de niro
stuff that people have been talking
about in the footage and sophie Turner
that plays itself out first before
bigger more personal problems come to
light like the fact that their brother
is secretly a Targaryen so number six
when bran and Samwell revealed the truth
of Jon Snow he learns everything at the
same time because there's a whole lot of
information heaped onto each other
contextually because one that his mother
was secretly good Lyanna stark and his
father was Rhaegar Targaryen just
learning who his mother was
is a really big thing for him but also
to learning that they secretly Wed
before he was born he's not a bastard
and has a legitimate claim to the throne
then all the characters sort of
processed this information in order of
increasing importance because some of
those things are more relevant than
others early in the season that later in
the season
that's way number five the first big
blow that he deals with is the identity
of his mother he asked about it in
Episode two season one and Ned Stark
said the next time we're together we'll
talk about your mother I promise so
conveniently because they've been
showing so many scenes of the characters
standing around Ned Stark statue in the
crypts of Winterfell in very literally
Ned Stark's remains are buried here it
stands a reason that they pay off that
setup of Ned Stark saying the next time
were together we'll talk about your
mother that Jon Snow learns the truth in
the presence of Ned Stark in the crypts
so that he can stare at Ned Stark's
statue while his brain is slowly melting
inside his head then he can turn and
walk to his mother lyanna stark's statue
like we see him walking past in that
last trailer video
and look upon her face knowing the truth
this has been my mother this whole time
and just sort of wondering you know
watching his brain go a thousand miles a
minute trying to process it all that's
why I think that number for the
characters processed the aegon targaryen
of it all after that towards the end of
the series he engineers avoid each other
for a little while after they learned
the truth of things because they've been
in a relationship so they throw up in
their mouths for a little bit so
obviously they don't want to be together
for a little while even though they have
feelings for each other and it takes the
rest of the season to process that
information and for Jon Snow to come to
terms with the truth of his identity
like he and the other stark children
eventually won't care who his father was
he grew up there brother
a stark of Winterfell and John
identifies as a stark so he's not
suddenly gonna turn on that immediately
after learning the truth but remember
how George R Martin keeps referring to
talking even though the ending won't be
the Lord of the Rings ending remember
how Aragorn took the entire run of the
Lord of the Rings series to the very end
before completely accepting the Royal
aspect of his identity this is who I am
and who I'm meant to be
Jon Snow is the most reluctant king of
the north that has ever been in the
north so by the finale he will have come
to full terms with his Targaryen
heritage in his relationship with
Daenerys it's not like everyone will
find out then the next episode they'll
all be totally cool with it so number
three obviously talking more about bran
Stark in the night King I know there's a
lot of theories about bran Stark's
ability time travel and being tied up in
the identity of the night king but I do
think that their fate is linked so that
once bran has completed his task of
defeating than I can because like benjin
said in this promo the night King and
the White Walkers are coming south
you'll be ready for them when they
arrive bran will have his full-blown
wizard battle with the night king but
the reason why he's on my death
predictions list at all is because he's
so powerful the ability that he has to
recall literally any moment of history
in samwell's ability to find that
information and contextualize it is
almost too powerful for the show so what
happens on a drama when the characters
get to safe or they get to opie usually
the writers take something away from
them so regardless of what happens with
the night king and the White Walkers and
Cersei one way or another they lose
their ability to get any kind of
information they want to
Brande henceforth either he goes
completely catatonic or he straight-up
dies in the attempt to kill the night
king but there's no way you can be that
powerful and then be completely safe
there's always consequences and because
Ramsay Bolton if you thought this was
gonna be a happy ending you haven't been
paying attention I think that brand even
though they will be successful and their
attempted stop the night King all of his
mental issues and problems won't
suddenly just magically go away number
two though really big one the show and
the books have been foreshadowing that
Daenerys would eventually become
pregnant again because the show is now
past the books in the last couple of
seasons the show has taken that idea way
further there were several scenes during
season seven foreshadowing that she
would become pregnant with Josh those
child and lay another dragon egg so
early prediction before the season 8
finale
Daenerys learns that she's pregnant
again and in time we'll lay herself that
extra dragon egg courtesy of Jon Snow
for all the death predictions that
people want to lay on her - regardless
of what happens in the finale she lives
to give birth to that baby the only way
that they could justify the timeline and
have her actually give birth on the show
would be to one say that she's
technically already an early term
pregnancy when they arrive at Winterfell
and then during the season episode 2
episode they have a couple big time
jumps to cross that nine-month gap or
two if Lord of the Ring style there's a
montage in the finale where they
flash-forward and she gives birth in
those flash forwards because they do
play it really fast and loose with the
way time moves episode 2 episode on the
show so it's not unprecedented for them
to jump forward in time a lot several
weeks at a time within single episodes
so we'll see how they deal with the
rapid transit system during season 8
because there's only six episodes and
they'll be going all over Westeros and
typically it takes a long time to get
from one place to another so that is a
way to explain how she could become more
and more pregnant heading into the
finale but number one probably biggest
prediction and they've been
foreshadowing this for a while that the
Iron Throne in the red keep will be
completely destroyed as they were in
Daenerys as visions in the house of the
undying but instead of it being really
melancholy like it was in the visions
because at that time Daenerys was so
focused on going back and reclaiming the
throne she's been so bent on it this
whole time by the finale she and John
won't actually care about the Iron
Throne anymore and even though it'll be
the end of the war for the dawn that'll
be a big success it won't be the end of
all the drama between the surviving
Great Houses she will still find a way
to temporarily break the wheel so to
speak but everything repeats so there's
no way that this will be the last war to
ever go down in Westeros because
Daenerys is story parallels Aegon the
Conqueror so much Aegon the conquerors
actual story of what it was like during
his reign is a good template for what
will probably happen going forward
beyond season aid what happened is is
that after Aegon conquered Westeros they
call that period of his life the reign
of the dragon he actually had to spend
the better part of his life flying all
over Westeros to keep the realm from
setting itself on fire constantly so
just because he conquered it and just
because he had balerion the black dread
and he was super powerful and everyone
was afraid of his power didn't mean that
suddenly nobody ever fought with each
other ever again he had to play the
political game for the rest of his life
so realistically assume that it's going
to be similar going forward in Westeros
even after they defeat the night king
post all your season 8 predictions in
the comments below and what will happen
is as this weekend is the Oscars and
it's also the true detective season 3
finale so I'm assuming that HBO is
either gonna drop another game of
Thrones trailer or they'll drop one a
couple days after so we should be
getting new Game of Thrones footage
really really soon of course I'll do a
video for whatever it is that they drop
leave your requests in the comments
below and congratulations to Bucky weady
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Game of Thrones video please email
me on the about page my channel so I can
get your details click here for my new
Arya Stark cleganebowl
Theory video and click here for all my
Game of Thrones season 8 episode
trailers and promo videos thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight